you blab is out and it is a snorefest
it's fraud it's abroad I wouldn't watch
it honestly it's like Joe Rogan light
will you ever see the Jaguar tripping
out on ayahuasca just replace the bald
buff dude with with a extremely white
blonde actress and just have have her go
like this for hours instead of actually
asking follow-up questions and they're
being used as treatment Renaissance of
psychopharmacology Zoloft psychiatry
left psychotherapy behind of terrible
side effects and right Enzi's I mean the
first four episodes guys they're not
controversial at all as you'd expect
from what is essentially a puff piece
from Netflix they basically don't
address any of the substantial
criticisms all they do is make it seem
like the goop lab is just asking
questions guys we're just asking some
questions isn't it shouldn't we be
allowed to ask some questions so that
goes on for four episodes you have
psychedelics wim HOF on you've got dupes
sexuality thing you've got a fasting
protocol all that until you actually get
to the until they start to unload their
normal crap on you it's it's an energy
healing summit or whatever and then in
the final episode they decide that
mediums exist and there are everyone's a
medium like you were an intuitive you're
a medium we all are and that's never
really challenged because all you have
is going to pouch show once again going
something to this and I can surrender so
it's all have a general idea of who I'm
speaking with you don't need a psychic
medium to prove it to you for the louder
your volume switches Wow oh yes yes
uh-huh
just like this extremely credulous but
never fully buying into it person and
you might be wondering after watching
all of it I mean if you don't know of
any of their substantial criticisms like
what are people so mad about this
docu-series or whatever you want to call
it was not that bad well that's only
because they didn't address any of the
substantial criticism and it's really
frustrating so I just want to lay out
for people why actually people are mad
it's not
because they're exploring psychedelics
you know it's not because they have wim
HOF on it's because they're they have
deceptive advertising and that hurts
people and they're charging money for
that snake oil under the idea that it's
gonna cure disease and they're still
doing it
so let's contrast the two the two
narratives right we have the Gwyneth
Paltrow narrative which we'll get to in
a second and we have like everybody else
so everybody else forever has been
saying hey goop we really don't like
that you're lying about what your
products do and do not do and that's
pretty much what their crit the
criticism has been forever they've
already paid in one hundred forty five
thousand dollar fine for doing this for
deceptive advertising for misleading
health advertising they already paid a
fine for that but if you ask one of
Paltrow that's not what it is at all
so Gwyneth Paltrow's narrative is
basically that they once had problems
but they fix them all so those are
mistakes that we made early on that we
don't make anymore and we have our own
science and regulatory team about
everything and now they're just being
hated on because of because they're
asking too provocative of questions like
talking about women's sexuality but then
there are certain things that just you
know I think especially around female
sexuality it's it seems to be an
incendiary topic for certain people
which I find really interesting who's
mad at them for talking about female
sexuality who's who's mad about them
find me this huge angry mob that's mad
about them because they're talking about
oh no they're talking about females
oh no the men are upset they're so mad
they're so mad about it
no people are mad about the
pseudoscience haven't suddenly don't do
anymore in fact and goopes whole thing
of like we don't do this anymore now we
have a science team yeah their science
team is about as scientific as a big
tobacco's science team trying to
discover that you know is there a link
between cancer and cigarettes that's
that's what the thing is because check
this out truth in advertising a couple
days ago just release this report that
in fact goop lab has not changed at all
they're still doing the same thing
so in in one of their perfumes which
they charge $55 for one of the
ingredients they claim treats negative
energy anxiety neurosis and OCD you
can't do that because it doesn't it's
not it's not proven to do that you can't
say it treats this I can't say you know
drinking this magical water cures you
know it treats cancer it doesn't it
doesn't so I can't say that right it's a
lie and people would be rightfully mad
at me if I said that so you can't say
that this agar would in your perfume is
treating OCD people are gonna buy the
perfume and like be like trying to cure
their cure their OCD they also sell this
g'tok stuff toxifying super powder which
they claim detoxifies your body of a bad
diet alcohol stress and environmental
toxins by fighting the free radicals oh
yes the free radicals are back and
they're being fought by goopes g toxin
of toxifying qatar super powder now do
they have any proof of that no so this
is what people are mad about and you're
not gonna find it in goop lab
unfortunately it's a gigantic
disappointment and they don't address
anything so I'm just here to tell you
why people are actually mad no it's not
because of Gwyneth Paltrow's like warped
narrative of oh they just hate me
because I'm asking very risque questions
no we hate goop because you're saying
Ana Garwood treats OCD no it doesn't
[Music]
[Music]